this is the moment the underwater hunger
tonga hunger herpai volcano erupted
it was an explosion so powerful it
triggered tsunami waves across the
island's shores
forcing residents to scramble to higher
ground while large traffic jams formed
as people tried to flee
waves swept through homes churches and
shops as locals were left facing a near
total power blackout it's said to have
been one of the biggest eruptions to
date this is uh
absolutely unique in my experience you
said i mean i've i've
lived in tonga five years worked in the
pacific and on tsunamis for 40 years
and uh whereas tonga
and that area of the pacific
we know there are tsunamis where there
hasn't been
an event from a
a volcanic eruption and such an
explosive
eruption previously the eruption was
reportedly heard as far as new zealand
and australia and tsunami alerts are in
place for parts of the west coast of the
united states
the full extent of the damage is
currently unknown but it's clear that a
trail of destruction has been left
behind aisha zahid sky news